i'm back [ __ ] haha i bet you thought
you wouldn't get a summer 2022 anime in
a nutshell did you but how could an eye
when last season we got spy x family
completely taking over your boy kong
ming dropping some fat bars summertime
render being the sleeper hit stuck in
disney jail shikimori sun proving she's
not just a cutie
she's also boring as [ __ ] but also we
saw the unthinkable happen kagia summer
took over full metal alchemist
brotherhood as the top-rated anime on
mao that's right the king of anime has
been dethroned by a rom-com what an
exciting time to be an anime fan and you
know what i had to come back because who
knows maybe we could even find something
to compete with that this summer because
this season we have your stepmom's
daughter is my ex
hey guys so i'm here today to announce
that i'm going on break again
[Music]
damn [ __ ] you live like this oh boy
oh boy oh boy boy boy boy oh boy hold on
guys this is a rare occasion so just let
me be that guy for a second
oh yeah so i read the manga for this
already your fukushima uta or call of
the night is a show you should have
already been highly anticipating because
you're a true gig fan and watch all the
videos i put out right guys
guys because i made a video about how
much i enjoyed this manga and after
watching these episodes i feel a new
sensation of unrivaled pride watching an
anime adaptation living up to a manga
that you like and with that comes this
new sensation of overwhelming
superiority that i knew about this manga
before the anime oh no
i'm turning into joey the real beauty of
this story is how it captures the sense
of freedom and serenity of wandering the
streets at night at least it does in
japan i don't know if you get the same
experience at 3am doing a casual stroll
through brixton and the anime absolutely
nailed it the color palette the music
the atmosphere if lo-fi was an anime
this would be it the show is v-i-b-e-s
lowercase double-spaced lettering vibes
not to mention the soundtrack has been
absolutely godly not just the
atmospheric tracks but pretty much every
insert song opening and ending has been
an absolute bop this is setting the
standard for the rest of the season but
before i talk about the rest of the
shows how about to talk about gentian
impact for a bit today's sponsor all
right guys let's be real you know i've
been deep in the gentian hall and i know
a load of you are deep in the engine all
as well it's okay you can be honest it's
a safe space here but in case you aren't
this is a massive open world action rpg
with a unique elemental combat system a
massive ever evolving storyline and even
a co-op mode it's a sensation that's
taken over our weave community seriously
if you've been to any anime convention
like me in the past few months every
third cosplay is like a gentian
cosplayer so i know there are a lot of
you out there and there's a reason for
that what can i say the waifus and
husbands are all mwah chef's kiss and
you know it's like a good game as well
in the newest 2.8 update right now
they're doing a summertime odyssey event
which includes a new co-op mode that
takes place in the golden apple
archipelago area resonating visions
which can give you a new four-star skin
for official and a new evermotion
mechanical painting puzzle game not
forgetting that kazuha cli and yoimia
will have returning banners along with a
new four-star character rip my primo
gems so what are you waiting for click
the link in the description to get
gentian on your devices right now but i
know what you guys are really waiting
for gentian players want one thing and
it's free stuff here's a gift code on
screen for some free prima gems and
adventurous experiences alright back to
the summer season lucifer and the
biscuit hammer now this is one of those
titles dedicated margaritas just won't
shut the hell up about this is a classic
manga that's loved by many so as you can
imagine expectations are high it's got
some big shoes to fill and
it's there it's [ __ ] i haven't even read
the manga and i can feel the
disappointment watching this feels like
watching the animation equivalent of
room temperature beer it's not horrible
it's just flat
like your mum what i see is a highly
beloved piece of work being adapted at a
level that satisfies absolutely no one
and you know guys i might not have read
this manga but i get it i do have seen
my favorite dojins animated by queen bee
anyway now for something completely new
never from the author of the strongest
sage with the weakest crest comes i
gained a second character class and
became the strongest sage in the world
they're the same picture oh i'm just
being facetious but i don't know why
this guy chose being the strongest sage
to be his gimmick finally a guy thinks
this is a cool original hook and i'll
find you a guy who gets stupidly excited
over the millionth esa cup
it's back
it's back i never thought this day would
actually come we've done it boys we've
memed another season into existence but
remember the fight isn't over yet
i normally like to gloss over the
sequels to give room for new shows but i
feel like the season is just so
top-loaded with sequels we waited nine
years for devil as a part-timer giving
us back the original mcdonald's isekai
classroom of the elite is back after
five years to save us from that hell of
a cliffhanger they ended on tokyo mumu
is back after 20 years with tokyo mew
mew new cindy's really excited about
this one because it's one of the shows
that got her into anime and i'm really
excited because it sets up for one of
the best sequel names of all time if we
get an eventual sequel to it tokyo mumu
nunu dain machi has reached its fourth
season same with overlord you know as
much as the cg ruined some of the
moments in season three i've still got
high hopes for this new season myanus is
fully prepared for more child torturing
lovecraftian horror induced existential
dread and made in the best season too
shout out to my boy kevin penkin for
doing some of his best work yet with the
music because i gotta say [ __ ] big
real cool mind but look the amazing
sequel train doesn't stop there as we
have rented girlfriend season two
[Laughter]
another season of one guy engaging in
the most maidenless behavior in the
history of mankind as a manga reader i'm
still waiting for the day someone rents
cosmos some grass so he can finally
touch it i don't even know why he's
allowed near any elderly people in the
hospital surely that's a health hat of
course
because surely they'd be in danger of
dying of cringe if you want some of the
best girls this season you can just
appreciate your fukushima utah instead
of tuning in on this and watching kazuma
out there appreciating your fukushi no
[ __ ] if you told me in 2013 that one
day i'd be watching a ruby anime coming
from studio shaft and genorobuchi i
would have slapped the [ __ ] out of you
to wake you up from your weeb fantasy so
i'll be the first to say well slap me
silly and call me chris because dear
lord just look at this blow up
[Music]
the only thing that makes me sad is that
i only wish monty um was here to see the
fruits of his efforts because even with
cuts like this there's just something
about his choreography the way his
battles have a certain fluidity actions
that flow from one to the next to the
next to the next like a tempo to a song
it was magical to watch and will never
be matched even in a beautifully
animated show like this the man really
was a genius but honestly who cares
about the fight scenes i know the real
reason we got a full anime budget was to
see some full 4k hd cookie eating sakuga
action this is the real glow up we
needed all right the cookies let me see
her eating the cookies oh my god there
it is here it comes here it comes
one out of ten worst adaptation ever
what are you doing i'm just sorting out
some trouble on my discord server oh i
can help mod that if you want wait you
more discord servers yeah i mean if you
got a subreddit or stream on twitch i
can help you mod that as well you're a
discord mod reddit admin and you more
twitch chat too
hot damn this is a great looking show
when a1 pictures want to turn it on they
can really turn it on which is a shame
because it feels like i'm watching a
forgettable early 2010s anime in 2022.
you got a yandere with pink hair a
tundra ex girlfriend people making out
in 4k sakuga and a dreary deadbeat
version of now foo me that every girl
seems to be fawning over for some reason
i mean what am i missing here is he a
nice guy does he have a good personality
is he rich and famous
is he not related by blood sibling
you remember that show the detective is
already dead from last year that had
amazing action scenes like this and
everyone's been talking about since huh
no you don't yeah this is gonna be one
of those shows is what i would be saying
if i didn't livestream my opinion about
it only to be told promised that it gets
better by episode three and after
watching it i gotta say
it was all right it's [ __ ] big titty
utter utter succubus wearing the virgin
killer sweater
that's that that's the show china wait a
minute summoning a familiar to make a
contract with them where you have to
feed them mana via bodily fluids to have
them stick around this is just fate
except it's really horny this is just
fate except it's got a big tittied
character without a harder energy this
is just fate except the viewers are just
raging degenerate this is just
fate we've got a show about young
magical girls hanging out their dorms at
a mage academy or something i believe
this one's called tiny witch academia
there's also reverse takagi-san for all
of you who are looking for a cute
rom-com this season yakuza's guide to
babysitting now this is a cute one
another show to add to the daughter
simulator genre of anime but
unfortunately we now live in a post anya
world who has just completely broken the
door to meta look this girl's adorable
and all but where's the meme faces
where's the waku-waku where is the
elegance honestly when your daughter
game is this strong i don't know how
anyone else is meant to compete
this does nothing you know if i had a
dollar for every pharmacy isakai anime
that's aired i'd have three which isn't
a lot but it's weird that has happened
three times in one year now out of all
the pharmacy isakai though this one
definitely grabbed me the most you have
an esteemed medical researcher being
esocarted to a world where the
understanding of medicine is primitive
at best while also being given the power
to diagnose any illness with just a look
and the ability to create any substance
as long as he knows the chemical
compound of it wanna cook crystal meth
having all the tools he needs to
completely revolutionize the world's
medical system honestly this was pretty
interesting and the most disappointing
thing about it is that we have yet
another death by overwork isekai which
is just depressing now let's be real
like does anyone miss the simpler days
of trucking come on man you've been
slacking recently oh maybe i spoke too
soon
you fell off so when i first saw the
title uncle from another world i was
like god damn they already are just
throwing words on the dartboard and
adding another world to it but it turns
out this was one of the best parodies of
isekai i've seen guy's uncle wakes up
from a 17 year long coma after a track
accident and it turns out he was easy
guy this entire time saving some far-off
fantasy world and the best part he's
managed to keep all his powers from that
world yes this is a post isekai story
but now back in the real world needing
to reacclimate to society what does he
decide to do with these powers
are you youtuber the show has more than
its premise though beyond its gimmick is
characters are genuinely funny and keeps
the show from becoming stale beyond its
meta hook basically it asks what would
happen if the person that got issachaid
was a [ __ ] idiot i think he speaks
volumes though that even in a parody
that's making fun of all the overused
tropes and one-dimensional characters in
isekai
i still unironically fell for the
[ __ ] tsundere
oh boy your stepmom's daughter is my ex
i appreciate that i tried to find a more
tasteful way to say i used to date my
step-sister but you can say [ __ ] like i
kind of fancy my first cousin first
removed dad's stepsister's daughter but
at the end of the day you still just
said you want to [ __ ] your sister mate
if i'm being real i was actually
expecting a bit more spice for the title
like this but this is way more wholesome
than i thought it was going to be like
they've got some proper sibling
bickering going on where's the spice
it's looking a lot less like domestic
ex-girlfriend and more like kagya summer
with a side of
[Music]
dumpster dive just yet it's just a
casual rummage through the
all dustbin this one actually looks half
decent out of the two anime original a1
pictures sci-fi show with cute girls in
them this one seems like the one to
watch you've got some kind of secret
defense force made up entirely of cute
anime girls because of course they are
focused on preventing crimes before they
happen what really stands out is the
action direction and gun battles the
choreography for these gun fights feels
like a mix between grounded action films
and the gun martial arts of equilibrium
which is pretty damn cool also i know
what i said before about best girl this
season but that might actually go to
chisato all right i'm not gonna lie this
is the kind of energy i need in my life
but beyond a natural charm she's able to
dodge bullets like she's in the bloody
matrix and can handle firearms like an
assassin on crack that's right she's
waifu keanu reeves would you like to buy
this slave slave did you say she was
your slave yes i am shocked i am
appalled why is it that every easy guy
has to include some kind of slavery in
some form or another nowadays you know
in my world we abolish slaves hundreds
of years ago because it was the right
thing to do and yet here it's not only
accepted but glorified you have sex with
her you know i mean can you not see the
morality of owning another human being
as property did you say she'll have sex
with me mm-hmm
[Music]
i'm absolutely watching this show guy
gets isight and finds out he's in a
world where he can buy slaves he can
sleep with so what does he do he goes
out to raise money to buy a harem of
slaves by killing bandits and collecting
their bounties my guy's out here
committing first-degree murder for the
promise of [ __ ] first to say slavery is
one of those tropes in isikai that i
think it's just the dumbest eye-rolling
[ __ ] especially when it's framed us oh
look guys the hero is the good guy for
buying the slaves to save them but this
is so deplorable so unethical that i
can't even find it offensive this is
coming from the same studio that made
interspecies reviewers and i am not
surprised if you're looking for culture
this season with no [ __ ] given this is
it the show didn't even pretend to have
any morals it stood up looked us dead in
the eye and literally went up yours woke
moralists
we'll see who cancels who now i don't
want to add into this overplayed trope
of slavery in east car but i swear to
god guys this is a one-off that's not
why i watch it look trust me not every
easy card needs to devolve into buying
slaves as a plot point are we clear on
that
all right good let's see what we've got
next
next time